while the struggle continues for a
european solution for the migrants on
lesbos the next refugee drama is now
unfolding
at another european external border the
canary islands
some 4 000 people have arrived by boats
since the beginning of the year hundreds
are thought to have died while making
the treacherous journey on the atlantic
ocean
many of them are fleeing the
deteriorating security situation in the
sahel with boats departing from morocco
and the territory of western sahara
they're also departing hundreds of
kilometers farther south from mauritania
and senegal while arrivals to
mainland spain fell by half compared to
the same period
last year landings in the canary islands
increased nearly
seven-fold the sea is surprisingly calm
this afternoon at least for weta ventura
abdul kamara and his friend ibrahim
toure remember well the high waves when
they arrived on the spanish island
they'd already spent three days on the
sea in a rubber dinghy
the atlantic crossing between africa and
the canary islands is considered the
most dangerous escape route in the world
suddenly we heard air leaking from the
rubber dinghy
at that moment everyone was scared to
death i had the feeling that this could
really be the end for us
i thought about my little sister who
would then be left without me
i thought about friends i would never
see again
[Music]
the leak was successfully patched and
abdul reached the spanish coast
in the last few weeks alone more than 1
000 migrants like him have arrived in
the canary islands
many mediterranean countries have
tightened controls against immigration
because of corona
and the well-trodden route via libya has
become dominated by criminal gangs
with such developments the dangerous
atlantic route has become increasingly
attractive
new arrivals are placed in largely empty
hotels the island's tourism association
has sharp criticism for the government's
decision
we're currently working to promote
ventura as a safe and clean island
that's in the best of health nobody
likes to see a hotel full of migrants
now
that's reality
at the government level island director
domingo fuentes
also receives criticism from other sides
human rights activists criticize that
the migrants are sealed off in hotels
and don't have access to asylum
procedures
they warn of conditions similar to those
in greece where the migrants lack the
most basic necessities
fuentes rejects the criticism
we are a southern external border of the
european union here
in the same way that the eu is currently
addressing the issues of migration from
the near and middle east
it should also address the problems
arising from migration here on the
southern border
and adding to the stress the government
sees growing concern over coronavirus
infection rates
immediately upon arrival people reaching
the island are tested
in one of the last groups half of the
tests were positive
many newcomers like kamara and today
want to leave the island as soon as
possible and move on to the european
mainland
where exactly they don't know yet the
main thing is a place where they can
find work and are safe from deportation
back home
let's go straight to fuente ventura now
in dws john phillip schultz good day to
you jan phillip spanish officials
are warning that the difficulties on
fuerteventura that we've just been
looking at will only be
increasing with the number of new
migrant arrivals set to surge
what are they expecting
yes exactly some people are already
warning that
there could be conditions like on lesbos
if the crisis continues for
too long and there are too many new
arrivals on a daily basis
the canary islands have already been a
popular
destination for migrants mainly 10
15 years ago then migration routes via
the mediterranean became
more popular but i think there are also
a lot of reasons
why the route via the canary islands is
becoming more and more popular again we
have
the problem that the conditions in libya
a typical transit country
the conditions there are horrible
migrants are kidnapped
sometimes even killed we have increased
border controls through the due to the
pandemic and
last but not least we have a lot of
desperate people in the countries of
origin especially in western africa
especially in the style
region there are more and more conflicts
and more and more desperate people
willing even to risk their lives what's
the spanish government doing to help
those
especially those whose lives become
endangered while
while making this very very difficult
crossing
not not enough at least that's what a
lot of activists say and that's also
what the human rights commissioner of
the european union
said in a state statement recently
they criticized that spain does not do
enough in the
uh search and rescue missions they also
criticize
bad housing conditions and especially
here on the canary islands a lot of
activists
criticize that migrants don't have
access to
proper asylum procedures they even speak
about deportations without a proper
legal basis and they stress the need for
more search and rescue missions briefly
if you could local politicians are
putting the blame
on the eu what do they want to see
happen
i think first of all they want more
attention of course all the focus is
on the eastern mediterranean especially
on greece
at the moment of course they also want
more financial aid from the european
union
but most of all i think they want what
most countries that have external eu
borders want
they want a european solution they don't
want to be left alone with the problem
jan phillips thanks very much for that
from fuerteventura
a police operation is now underway on
the greek island of lesbos to move
thousands of migrants and refugees
into a new temporary tent city many have
been sleeping on the streets after
a fire destroyed their refugee camp
authorities say the operation has so far
passed off peacefully but
many migrants are reluctant to move into
the new facility
rows of tents on the greek island of
lesbos
they've been set up for migrants
displaced by the fires that gutted the
maurya camp
on thursday greek police started moving
hundreds into them
over the past few days migrants had
chosen to stay on the streets in squalid
conditions
many saying they'd rather remain here
than run the risk of being detained for
months in a completely new camp
some have even returned to what remains
of moria
they said the temporary tents are not
enough they want
long-term solutions
they put us in a place where there's no
life and it's like a jungle
a human cannot live in such tents
early on wednesday only about 1 200 of
the roughly 13 000 migrants rendered
homeless by the fires
had moved to the new temporary
accommodation the un refugee agency said
there is capacity for about another 8
000 people
and had urged people to move it had said
it's the only way forward
people who have been in moriah can come
to this camp and we encourage them to
come there
because it's from here that their
process will continue
that their procedure will continue that
solutions can be found
and that people can leave the island
because
the idea is not that people remain
forever
on the island of lesvos but while
several european states have offered to
take in migrants from lesbos
others say they will not they're
offering to provide more aid
and even more tense instead
let's get the very latest now with darth
natalis a journalist
on lesbos good day to you daphne can can
you tell us
about the police operation now underway
to
move the migrants and refugees into the
new tent city that we
just saw being set up hello from the
island of lesbos
yes indeed there was a police operation
that started very early in the morning
uh right before uh dawn actually police
forces
uh brought riot buses and they blocked
off
the road where the people have been
staying for the past eight
or nine days uh they blocked off the
road so that
people would not leave and sort of
contain them in this area where they
have been staying
already all these days uh there's the
traffic has been
disrupted since uh since then since the
people are living here on the streets
the shops on the area some a couple of
supermarkets
and gas stations have been they cannot
they cannot operate so since this
morning
the police went around to people and
and told them that they will have to go
to the new camp
to access facilities there water
electricity they will be registered
there in the new site again they will be
handed
non-food items sleeping bags tents
a smaller test actually because there
are tents there
and other non-food items that they that
the agencies the aid agencies are
providing
and uh there's at the moment the latest
that i have is that
there's 2 300 people around 2
300. okay i want to get to that question
how many people are not going into the
camps and how many have already
moved into the new facilities
so um the latest information is that
at least 2 300 people have
gone since uh yesterday morning in
in the camp the operation started seven
in the morning very early
uh where peop where police authorities
were waking up people telling them that
they will have to pack their stuff
and slowly head to the camp it's not a
it's not a big distance
to walk or over there and there's still
many people that
are reluctant to go to the new facility
they
they think or they have heard that there
is not
there's no water they told me that they
think that there's no electricity
or that they're going to be closed in
the camp and will not be able to
to come out okay there's
also um we have to leave it there daphne
thanks so much for bringing us up to
date
on the situation right now uh at the
moria camp there
right outside it on lesbos thanks very
much
well the european parliament's due to
discuss the situation on lesbos during
today's debate our correspondent
barbara basil standing by for more on
that barbara
can we expect the eu to agree to a
common approach to
resolving the situation on lisbos
there is a no wonder no common approach
because as we know this is the most
poisonous political battleground in the
european union so
even when this debate was scheduled in
the european parliament there were some
right-wing and some populist parties who
said
we don't want this debate uh you know
where is the problem it was the refugees
themselves who are supposed to have put
the camp
set the camp on fire and so we we don't
want to talk about this
but we just of course the debate is
taking place there is a majority against
that very hard line
uh position but it shows how deep the
divisions go
we just heard the the european
commissioner ilv johansen
the commissioner for refugees and she
said progress on maurya
is slow and that is like we just saw
people
mistrust the the the local
the police and the people on the ground
and and they say we don't want to go in
those camps anymore because we'll
be stuck there forever and after five
years of people being stuck in moria
no wonder so solutions here are
difficult at the moment
the discussion just goes about getting
more humanitarian aid there
and there is no real long-term or even
medium-term solution inside it seems
okay we're focusing right now on moria
but greece is not the only country with
an eu extra
external border that's currently
struggling with an influx of migrants
absolutely not nobody's talking about
spain because the the southern europe uh
southern mediterranean route
has been sort of come back to life
towards the end of last year
people mostly from the sahel area in
conflict
conflict zones down there like mali uh
people from cameroon and so on
they've been moving up through morocco
and and they have now
ended up on the on the canary islands
and it's the same situation
we don't have exact figures but it's
several thousand people that
have arrived there already and uh it's
the same situation as in greece
the islands are a bottleneck and the
greek
the the greek authorities are not the
spanish authorities are not willing or
not capable of moving people on from
there
same situation again because they say
nobody in europe is taking these
refugees off our hands
there is no redistribution and that is
still the point we're stuck at
barbara thanks so much for looking into
this as that debate continues today
in uh brussels thank you very much